who has your best interest in mind and
where do those interests lie these are
fundamental questions in terms of
governance in the Constitution in the
preamps as We the People in order for
our perfect union
didn't say me the state didn't say we
the national security agency to say me
the president says we the people there
are elements in the government the
secret side of government wants to
basically data colonize the United
States that's where we're headed
if I come to you I ask you to turn over
all the keys to your house and your car
and your lock boxes and your safety
deposit boxes and all your accounts and
passwords and financial and email all of
your social media accounts including the
IDS and all of their passwords